I am a huge fan of French I've watched
every episode I loved that show
is it too soon to talk about you know a
revival or reboot or anything with
French you know it's interesting we
talked about a Jeff Pinkner JJ and I
talked about at one point for me the
heart of Fringe is guy named Jeffrey he
wrote most recently young he co-wrote
the last two Jumanji movies but he is
he's just a wonderful writer and a
wonderful man and a wonderful showrunner
and and we did we talked to Warner
Brothers about it we talked to ourselves
but ultimately we sort of didn't find a
way through we're so it's not too soon
is it too late I don't know it's not in
the offering right now for the people
that have never seen fringe a great show
worth your time I mean I was just a huge
fan of you know
the alt world and what you guys were
able to pull off with you know a budget
thank you we uh it's funny it's trending
now unlike you know the way your Apple
TV tells you what people are watching
somehow there was like this weird Fringe
resurgence which then became this funny
little text chain between all of us guy
fringe is trending yeah why wouldn't it
be ya know it was it was a delight to do